olá a todos pessoal de quem fala é o dar
que seja muito bem vindo é mais um vídeo
e hoje vou que jogar referiu se
experimentar os mapas próximo fizeram
não é história ao quebrar os games
eu espero que vocês não tenham feito
mapas não é ok vamos lá que fazer uma
pesquisa por dar frama e eu tenho que 36
mapas de pessoal por isso muito obrigado
a vossa estude e continua em fazer mapas
se realmente querem que esta série
continua então bora lá o primeiro mapa e
vamos a um play now o latitude pessoal
daqui quem fala ajudar que sejam bem
vindos mas o descanso o gato
após ser chamativo vocês fazem mapas
muito difíceis vocês não deixam ele é
mais um vive mais um vive é e dos
internos e consigo salário milagre eu
sou eu sou jesus viu-se agora falei tudo
eu consigo para lá sem pernas grosso
juventude eu sugiro um autêntico milagre
para o melhor outubro de sempre fará
dois pontos é o 11 é este mar exprom
gosta da arcas próprio gosta da mpb este
vídeo
então bora lá dar um play now e ou o
último dia que o mapa muito colorido e
saiba que ratos é diferente ok
vá em frente e cai dark rock e isso
chateia é uma armadilha mas vamos lá eu
consegui passar não é porque um texto
aqui este semanais meu morte não é e sem
meu o gado está cheio de pessoas mortas
é é filho ajuda 58.610 calma vamos ver e
eu saltar
calma calma não não
[Música]
mark free on board pessoal sabe por que
vocês têm que aumentar o volume é
intervir no fim porque está em
entendimento a ilha
ok eu vou explicar e agora vou seguir
aqui é família e fui isso não é então
para lá dar cuidado com ela ou kv bicho
11 filmando uma que o zé manel sem
cabeça e não tinha conhecimento
isso não vai ficar assim assim numa
assim há sim uma manutenção passando por
cima de wilson filho ficou embaixo não
podem não ter calma calma a moeda isso a
boa forma
só eu sei a minha filha e se eu não
ficava lá à frente mas pronto não
interessa agora é calma time seguir
entreguei minha primeira vez aqui em
causa está uma moça o anúncio que eu sou
muito forte meu impulso de outubro o
dólar não ficou até o final do ano
falta isso nunca nem é é boa pois é eu
ia estimar é muito fácil é o sistema é
fácil
desta vez tenha minha filha comigo eu
acho não é fácil mas estava em uma fila
e sem cabeça mas não dá conta que
funciona funciona o que importa é o
corpo só o que importa é que haja
apuração em casa amor e eu acho que a
negociação anual não ponderou toibin
correu mal isto correu muito e eu
preciso de ajuda
digo isso muito bem dar que agora só não
deixe que a bola tinha certa a união nem
nível de desvio do foco agora dessa hora
desta manhã já não celebrou
já no seu micro camec isso a madrinha da
tribo google cair por outro lado embora
e agora onde é que podemos pernas e eu
espero que esteja telemar com os dedos
anulá la
agora meu deus o que eu já vi hoje que
apagar o incêndio do shopping que os
comandam a água só que uma decisão
yana lá anda lá amanhã agora é onde o
fim acho que já passei um fim
já para já fazer o vinho não é louco não
existe uma próxima vez jogava eu passo
por querer mesmo ainda sob o regime de
psf planejar pra mim mas daí caiu o
aparelho como eu voltei lá mas tudo
outra vez
ana lá sempre sem partido porque aí eu
disse sempre tizio em que uns em parte
joel região eo tacuchian e isso agora
que ela vai ter que esperar que o aljube
aí vamos pensar passo a passo a passo a
passo a passo muito bem jogado da
arquibancada é rápido porque não perde
um mapa
agora a lei que era um robô abobo
encontra encontrar agora vamos ter que
avançar estudo e olha o fim era o lado e
viu seu vídeo de abril e fiz um mapa por
voz e espero que goste claro que vou
gostar é claro que eu gosto disso nossos
mapas pessoal muito obrigado mesmo é
quem perdeu o seu tempo fazer mapas pra
mim e vamos lá então escolher qual agora
vamos querer família fj veja lá o garçom
e picos
daqui pra matar matar a minha família
toda é basicamente foi isso que
aconteceu é uma cápsula tem que escolher
um gás mais fininho supostamente é ele
não eu vou que o indiana jones um guia
jonas lá isso espero um carro fiquei sem
cabeça ministro isso não devia ter
acontecido lá não não não não vou mais
fininho de todos que é este aqui eu acho
que estava lá
isso eu acho que não falta tanto mas o
funcionário estava passando quando
estava quase ao cair vamos alta isso não
aconteceu não eu sou uma minhoca e esse
não é não
eu ia dizer que os melhores conseguem
passar os níveis não não
o tumulto que deixou 17 pessoas e
cantaram músicas do ep uso você passar
os mapas está comprovado está a
comprovar isso e vamos lá o próximo papa
que é é pois ok tenta ganhar ok play now
vou escolher o uso do jardim porque eu
ganhei muito mais com a escada
o que aconteceu aconteceu
eu só não quero que isso aconteça não
poder ser ou não que não dá não dá este
mapa é impossível eu te conto tem com as
vendas compras lá tava lá em cima já
saiu já sei já sei calma calma já saiu
já sei pouco 10 com 10 havia lá embaixo
na terra embaixo
vocês pensam que enganam mais ninguém
não facilitando o primeiro foi não me
deram ok a nordeste de sanaa
eu morri eu só estava sem pernas eu
passei o último mapa sem pernas eu
passei o último mapa sem pernas chinesa
não consigo tá bom então tá bom de bola
e só vamos lá pra um mapa seguinte e
darfur em dois jogos ainda tudo isto o
ladário lembra-te de mim fiz outro mapa
preta inspirada em flaine tevez darfur
em dois esperam que gosta e como sempre
volume no máximo até perder justo empate
ouviram falvo no máximo é e qualquer
palavra sainz e concedia e que o epp
wilson não deixa por oca e eu acho que
tá explicar com o prius nos deixam terá
sempre uma coisa sem passiva e vamos lá
o pessoal isso é o de menos oficial foi
que eu fiz um primeiro mapa map world
por isso muito obrigado por ter feito o
segundo e para lá então julgaram é o
mapa supostamente escondem times é ok
a radar lembra de mim fiz outro mapa em
sua homenagem o que acho que é mesmo
isso não espero que goste tanto quanto o
outro por sorte tenho me inscrevo nesse
mapa e da arquiteta está muito melhor e
espera não está está melhore muito bem
em andantes é disfarçarem mesmo vou
falar do meu
- o espera lá tá com uma formiga foi o
banheiro floresta e montanha espero que
ir ao banheiro estava de burrada que é
privada e não fazia meu não não vamos
embora não partilhe bacia não se firmam
um filho morrer
o e75 é tarde é isso o que a ana lá não
há uma tarde apanhei na espera
cuidado buracos não me vejo nem houve
uma filha morrera pouco não me liga até
amanhã
no caí calma isso agora estava e e
acelera por vamos terminar um salto
muito alto isso bull mudar o controle da
bicicleta ok werneck caia é que eu sei
eu sei que a resposta não queria isso
isso eu tô sem braço eu tô sem braço mas
eu consigo conduzindo uma bicicleta
ainda o pai tem duas palavras do jovem
estava eu diz duas notáveis ainda foi
instável é o distinto só vão estar de
amarelo e por sermos um grande time e
amarela em nada ao acaso
bora lá e já tem três fatores duas
postas 2015 continua ou pêra albufeira
faltavam dois supostamente darfur em 2
este mapa uma conclusão para darfur em
2000 para mais mapas de darque frango
claro um lado e entre outros mapas estão
embora a jogar esses mapas do lar que
forem 2 que é uma conclusão supostamente
tipo 1 graus e dodô
olá a todos parece que gostaram do outro
mapa vou fazer outro se quiserem e põe
este mapa de conclusão do outro novo
floraí apug é e só sempre apoiar e
investir de chumbo foi que o favorito
neste vídeo também para me apoiaram a
apoiarem esta série e
jesus estava bom acaba nunca tinham
feito só pelo bom eu fui bater na bola é
isto e isto é mau não é possível é
impossível não consegui escapar um pouco
ansioso mas acha que isso é uma linha
baixar a cabeça com uma vez acabou
maiores páginas também empurraram e não
consegui
eu morri com um vidro espelhado no
pescoço podem mais notável
vejam bem que ela vai lá em frente nós
vamos conseguir passar este mapa e
qualquer afinal aquela bomba ajuda de
assaltar não é acabar com as bandas
todas ainda não só ganhou uma planta bom
fiz uma maneira não é nada de jackson
apenas aos do resto link para cima de um
carro numa mesa más da fita fazer os
cinco saltos mais longos que conseguiu
os dois pontos de stefhany rir muito
obrigado por ter feito este mapa embora
lá então fazer um salto do resto não há
nenhum este torci muito por onde anda lá
muito boa para mim e não o que está em
cima da mesa mas isso não funciona assim
não funciona assim o placar não não
vamos contar para escutar através de uma
garra camisa
agora surgiu ensina
tentei
um tento entender que é muito bom ter
sentido um país como a mãe sim isso
contribui com mais força
então é isso pessoal nós vamos ficar
porque com mais uma produzem scritti
politti já sabem se quiserem que esta
série realmente continuam façam os novos
mapas deixe vossa políc favorito fiquem
bem até a próxima
[Música]